josée legault stéphanie chouinard alec
castonguay bonsoir bonsoir
depuis dimanche donc depuis ce lien
entre le rapatriement du pouvoir à
québec sur la réunification familiale
douze mille personnes à peu près par
année dont la moitié ne parle pas
français donc depuis que monsieur le
bois fait ce lien et la survie du
français louisianisation c'est reparti
la pile est bon bien sûr fin de session
parlementaire à québec alors l'homme
mais c'est plus large que seul on voit
que le débat est relancé sur
l'immigration joue fantasy vous le
voulez bien d'abord avant la discussion
monsieur legault qui en reparle
aujourd'hui et ce matin et je vais vous
faire suivre ça tout de suite d'un
échange entre députés du parti libéral
et et simon jaulin
je voulais qu'on peut pour prendre un
exemple même trois glands puis à partir
de ces exemples les ai tous les
québécois qui arrivent ici puisqu'ils
connaissent pas le français apprennent
le français
avant de parler à la maison c'est pas
des appâts du premier ministre lorsque
monsieur le président ils vont aller
travailler ensemble sur le lieu de
travail mais il s'exprime en français
lorsque ils vont aller se réunir pour
une partie de son corps au hockey dans
l'espace public au magasin lorsqu'ils
vont aller faire des achats monsieur le
président ils vont le parent français
lorsqu'ils vont aller souper ensemble
que c'est des locuteurs de langue
maternelle distinguent ils vont utiliser
leur il a brandi à l'épouvantail de la
louisiane pour créer un effet de
diversion pour qui de plus de divisions
au sein des québécois et ça c'est
inacceptable
quand est ce qu'on va y a six québécois
c'est grâce député de laval des rapides
ici toute personne qui est au québec est
un québécois est ce que les québécois
veulent c'est que nos clients communs ce
soit le français le contrat moral de
l'immigration n'a jamais eu la langue
parlée à la maison
si c'est vers là qui va y aller ils vont
nous trouver nous devons jamais nous
retirer ce droit là le québec est une
des sociétés les plus accueillantes et
les plus ouverts dans le monde mais ok
mais on doit accueillir en français les
personnes migrantes qui vous savez
monsieur le président l'expérience parti
libéral au pouvoir ça a été négligé le
français
ça c'est un échange en euros dont je
vous faire entendre d'autres extraits
plus tard mais on commence avec ça
ce polo qui dit moi à la maison je peux
peut-être encore parler la langue que je
veux mais à l'extérieur je parle le
français je vous remet en jeu le tableau
que j'ai montré tout à leur langue
parlée à la maison le comme sur le goût
d'isabelle et les projections montrent
que ça va baisser 74% en 2036 anglais
qui augmente et langue utilisée le plus
souvent au travail le dernier tableau
mesdames et messieurs je vous promets
53% à montréal le reste du québec 85
donc deux mondes on le dit depuis le
début et 18% l'anglais 3 % dans le reste
du québec alors il ya deux façons de
montréal ceux ci ont duré du québec
josée est ce que ce débat là ça va dans
la bonne direction
tout à fait pour le moment ça c'est
certain ben on savait que moi ma
spécialité universitaire c'est la
question linguistique
j'ai beaucoup étudié le sujet j'avais
même coup signé le premier rapport à 81
96 qui allumait déjà des voyages on a tu
donc moi j'ai l'impression de vivre jour
de la marmotte mais
si je peux vous dire le fond de ma
pensée j'ai écouté monsieur legault ce
matin en point de presse mme aussi très
attentivement j'ai même lu la
transcription pour être sûrs après que
j'avais bien entendu jamais entendu et
j'avais l'impression d'assister à un
mauvais cours de démo linguistique
monsieur legault essayait d'expliquer
des concepts comme les transferts
linguistiques parce que c'est ça la
langue parlée à la maison la langue
d'usagé et un transfert linguistique
comme ça se fait au canada anglais de
manière tout à fait naturelle vers
l'anglais dès la première la deuxième ou
la troisième génération pour les
nouveaux arrivants sommes qu'au québec
pour le français jabra des lois ça prend
c'est si ça prend ça le rebond mais il y
avait de la difficulté ils maîtrisent
pas les concepts et je me suis dit bon
c'est le rôle de son minutes j'en ai
barrettes de faire cette pédagogie là
c'est pas le rôle du premier ministre de
toute manière et une dernière chose que
je me suis dit que je me suis dit il
manque un gérald godin dans ce
gouvernement on se souvient sous rené
lévesque qui avec améliorer le père la
loi 101 tout ce travail extraordinaire
mais il y avait aussi un petit peu après
l'arrivée gérald godin dragonette
ministre de l'immigration et des
communautés culturelles aujourd'hui on
n'a pas de rsa la diversité c'était
quelqu'un qui avait des antennes dans
les communautés qui tuerait kevin
sensibilité et qui ramener ça à son
premier ministre et monsieur legault il
n'y a pas ça non plus alors
il ya des gens ce qui manque aux rêves
rhodia les stratégies politiques et il
ya déjà des choses de base qui manquent
pour éviter que des gens se sentent
montré du doigt se chante même si on
leur disait 'je et responsables
individuellement les choix que vous
faites à vue individuellement ne sont
pas les bonbons stéphanie qu'est-ce que
à l'extérieur du québec s'intéresse
encore quel regard vous portez sur ce
débat là qui reprend
ouais on trouve on trouve ça un peu
problématique surtout de s'attarder sur
la langue parlée à la maison lorsqu'on
entend le mini jaulin barrette parler
d'immigrants qui se retrouveraient
autour d'une table au restaurant faut se
rappeler que
le français au québec c'est la langue
publique commune et c'est tout à fait
compréhensible est souhaitable que on
amène les immigrants à parler la langue
publique commune mais d'être bilingues
ou trilingues ce n'est pas un crime et
il ya quelque chose de tout à fait
louable à ce que ces individus la veille
aussi passer leur langue maternelle leur
langue d'héritage à leurs enfants comme
les francophones en situation
minoritaire à l'extérieur du canada
continue de le faire parfois avec l'aide
de l'état provinciale où ils sont
parfois un peu par contre dans lequel
vous fout et donc
c'est cet aspect là mocky que je trouve
extrêmement problématique qu'on oublie
que de parler français ça se fait avec
d'autres langues incluant l'anglais mais
aussi qu' on ne peut pas s'immiscer dans
la vie privée des gens et que c'est
l'anglais que les migrants apportent au
québec ça devrait aussi être vu comme
comme une richesse culturelle qui
appartient au québec alec sur la
louisianisation monsieur le bois a quand
même nuancé bon il y avait côté discours
politiques partisans dimanche là
aujourd'hui il dit bon ben oui t'es
peut-être une expression qu'on a déjà
entendu plusieurs fois dans l'histoire
du québec mais il dit c'est pas demain
matin
mais on a l'impression qu'ils ont voulu
replacer il a voulu ne plus faire le
lien direct entre le rapatriement du
pouvoir d des immigrants réunification
familiale et la survie du québec clottey
de se sortir de ce de cette équation qui
était peut-être un peu trop
s'inquiétait aussi nettement exagéré
large aux heures les moins de 5% des
louisianais qui parlent français ni
aucune loi pour protéger la bonne
jamais eu plus de 30 % de francophones
en louisiane le dernier recensement
québec montre que 94 % des gens vivent
au québec était capable de conversation
c'est le restant ce mois ci une
déclaration volontaire mais on n'est pas
moins de 5 % ça n'arrivera pas louisiane
ça n'arrivera pas au québec peu importe
par quel lorgnette on le prend donc pas
dit qu'il était temps de recadrer un
petit peu ce débat là
c'est difficile à comprendre un peu vous
envoie le gouvernement avec ça parce que
dont la langue parlée à la maison la
langue maternelle c'est pas des
statistiques qui ont beaucoup de valeur
dans déplaise à certains démographes
évidemment question immigrants arrivent
ici vos contenus par les le sa langue
maternelle à la maison s'il est capable
de travailler en français d'évoluer dans
l'espace public en français ça va
demeurer slalom commune pour tous et ils
vont être leurs enfants aient eu
francisée et c'est comme si le
gouvernement n'avait pas conscience
d'avoir ses propres programmes de
francisation et si c'est le cas ils
n'ont qu'à mettre plus d'argent et plus
d'efforts l'autre côté là et en leur
propre loi 96 qui viennent juste de
passer et qui avait toute une série de
modifications pour que la langue d'usagé
au travail soit le français on
assujettis les plus petites entreprises
à la langue à la loi ce qu'ont été les
lois semblent donc la charte de la
langue française on l'exigence d'avoir
des postes bilingues devrait être
beaucoup plus encadrée parce que c'est
vrai que maintenant il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises d'exiger exige des
postulants un mois alors qu on pourrait
tout à fait occuper ce postulation ne
pas que français et toute une série de
petites mesures qui sont intéressants
dans la loi 96 c'est comme si le
gouvernement le demandait pas j'ai pas
confiance en ma loi 96 je peux
conscience non plus on met programme de
francisation donc faut vraiment que je
me concentre sur les 6000 personnes qui
arrivent par année la réunification
familiale qui parlent pas français comme
si c'était une menace dans le grand tout
québécois
c'est ce qui est de l'art de
positionnement politique parce que sa
typo la route sur un point sur le point
statistiques sur le plan statistique et
c'est ce qui est un peu déroutant dans
ce débat là depuis 2 3 georges l affaire
de la réunification familiale comment
vous avez compris sur vous
mais comme une maladresse ou si c'est ça
c'est que là le premier ministre qui
s'en prennent à plusieurs directions en
même temps et
c'est passé pas toujours c'est pas
toujours très claires mais si je peux
revenir parce que je trouve ça vraiment
triste fait revivre ce que j'ai vécu y
aurait un caleçon sur la question de la
situation du passé les transferts
linguistiques c'est quoi un transfert
linguistique c'est lorsqu'une personne
immigrante
poids cette personne là mais peut-être
ses enfants ses petits-enfants deuxième
troisième génération madani peuvent bien
gardé leur langue maternelle mais pour
leur langue d'usagé en général à la
maison au travail de rééducation adopte
la langue officielle ou la langue de la
société ça se fait tout seul pour la
régler au canada anglais ça se fait pas
tout seul au québec et c'est statistique
canada qui mesure ça depuis des
décennies des décennies ce sont des
données fondamentales pour comprendre le
rapport de force entre le français et
l'anglais au canada régler et au québec
et au québec le problème c'est que on
les transferts linguistiques au bout de
deux trois générations ne sont pas dans
une proportion suffisante pour assurer
que le français demeure à long terme une
langue dominante vraiment une loge
exclut la minorité anglophone évidemment
casser ses droits ses institutions et
c'est donc et c'est le seul endroit au
canada ou la mort sociale d'une province
est concurrencée par une autre langue
c'est à dire le français concurrencé par
l'anglais comme langue d'intégration au
canada anglais l'anglais peu concurrencé
par le français comme langue
d'intégration mais c'est pour cela en
vrai josé qu'est ce que vous voulez en
politique ça ne s'explique pas
facilement ces choses-là cdsp ça prend
des spécialistes ça prend des pédagogues
et là c'est pour ça que c'est en train
de prendre des proportions et l'on peut
croire que les tables à aller dans le
seul salon des gens pour mesurer qu'est
ce qui pend dans leur salon non je me
suis hissé statistique canada qui mesure
sa maison josé je sais pour finir
cette boucle à vous dit
l'indicateur langue parlée à la maison
pour vous vous dites c'est important
parce que ça dénote bien sûr que c'était
ça dénature yeux un transfert
linguistique complet
voilà aimé tout gardé sa langue
maternelle aussi ça n'exclut pas
d'autres la rencontre même s mais qu'est
ce que vous voulez ce sont ce sont des
bottes des mots linguistique et lorsque
ça rentre dans le domaine politique ben
là on voit que ça scheer c'est bien
c'est bien certain mais je trouve ça
vraiment triste qu'on nous fasse qu'on
commence à nous faire croire que le
français va être sauvée seulement si on
le parle de manière publique c'est pas
vrai ce que c'est un travail de longue
haleine comme il suit tout seul pour
l'anglais n'en reste qu'un hier à ce
panel christian dufour jh est le vraie
débauche postale vrai débat c'est le
nombre d'immigrants qu'on soit au canada
et donc je dis si le canada reçoit
beaucoup plus québec décident dans ce
bois - le poids du québec va baisser
ou sur un an soit plus c'est dangereux
pour la langue alors il est si ça le
vrai débat qu'on n'arrive pas à faire un
tour de table rapide elle est juste que
c'est trop ça le vrai débat monsieur
legault le fait un peu en disant je
plafonne mes alec le pq a pas annoncer
de chiffres ils s'en vont vers là aussi
est ce qui compliquait dans ce débat là
c'est que le respect de la langue mais
l'aspect aussi les croissances
économiques relations du travail la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
s'entrechoquent 9,0 au canada anglais
josé raison n'a pas le même
tiraillements avec la langue on peut
accueillir plus d'immigrants donc la
plus de main d'oeuvre formée parce qu'on
a besoin de ces migrants là et comme le
québec lui bien le plafonne quelque part
la caq 10 1 4000 avant c'était 50-50
2012 les libéraux maintenant une
politique différent mais on a une
fourchette qui de toute façon on ferait
en sorte qu' on va moins de poids au
sein du canada parce qu'on est rendu à
400 milles par ani dans la caisse du
canada donc c'est énorme alors oui c'est
cette espèce de tiraillements mais il
est pas facile à résoudre moi je pense
qu'on devrait mettre beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts sur la francisation sur les
compétences jardin de certaines
catégories deming a qui arrivent ici qui
devrait déjà parlé c'est mais il faut qu
on en accueille il faut qu on en
accueille sinon on va en déclin des mois
grâce et complet
comme s'il y avait deux mots enfin
stéphanie
oui d'une part j'aimerais dire que
l'anglicisation des me diront canada ça
se peut pas en claquant des doigts non
plus et qu'il ya un problème dans
certaines communautés ce qu'on appelle
la ghettoïsation ou sur plusieurs
générations parfois on a on a un
problème avec
la langue publique commune donc c'est
pas tout à fait vrai le que ça se fait
de façon automatique au canada en game
malgré évidemment l'omniprésence de la
langue anglaise donc c'est des problèmes
qui sont différents de celui le auxquels
le québec fait face évidemment mais vous
quand même pas faut quand même pas sûr
simplifiée sinon comme le dit aller
évidemment le québec a un enjeu
particulier doit l'état l'état québécois
doit mettre de l'avant plus de de
soutien pour accueillir les migrants
pour les franciser pour ceux pour qui ce
n'est pas déjà fait dans le cas de la
réunification familiale on voit que
c'est quand même une portion importante
mais si l'économie québécoise veut
continuer de croître à moins d'avoir des
politiques familiales qui surpassent
celles qui existent déjà et qui sont
déjà plus généreuse à de nombreux égards
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve dans le reste
du pays je crois pas que le québec va
s'en sortir josé web à l'immigration
c'est important pas seulement pour des
raisons économiques c'est important pour
le tissu social de toutes les sociétés
occidentales c'est important d'avoir des
sociétés diversifiées et c est ça compte
pour quelque chose mais en même temps au
québec il faut préserver la langue
française donc il faut marier ces deux
nécessités là et oui ça prend plus de
programmes de francisation moi j'aurais
étendu la loi 101 aux cégeps à la
moindre hausse à la moindre hésitation
mais ça prend aussi à cause de ce choc à
cause de cette concurrence de l'anglais
comme langue d'intégration québec qu'au
canada anglais j'aimerais faire ben ça
prend aussi plus démunis pour ceux que
la sélection que le québec controls qui
soit maîtrise déjà le français avant
d'arriver ou qui sont ce qu'on appelle
des francos trope c'est-à-dire qui
parlent une langue qui va être proche du
prince et ça prend un mélange de tout ça
c'est très complexe ok ça prend du temps
pour faire les débats étaient des gens
là dessus puis voilà c'est ce qu'on
souhaite la au cours des prochains mois
vers une campagne un bond en ontario
c'est fanny on le voyait avec notre
collègue bon c'est réglé pour la
première place à moins d'une gigantesque
surprise qu'est ce que ça vous dit parle
à peu près plus aux journalistes il s'en
va vers une victoire scellée vraiment la
lutte pour la deuxième place que vous
suivez demain aussi en ontario ouais
donc d'une part du côté des
progressistes conservateurs auraient
fait une campagne très très cynique ans
a été presque la loi de l'omerta c'est à
jouer que les candidats et les
candidates sur le terrain ont fait très
peu de débats très peu d'apparitions
publiques ça a été la même chose pour
d'autres foires qui a très peu parlé aux
journalistes est évident du 14 mars se
bat pour pour la deuxième place et ont
passé plus de temps ça va qu'il les uns
les autres que d'attaquer d'oxford avec
le résultat qu'on est à peu près au même
point maintenant qu'on l'était ya 34
jours merci beaucoup on va on a pris le
temps de parler de la langue il y avait
d'autres extraits mais ça venait pas mal
à tout ça merci à vous trois ans on se
reparle très bientôt au revoir à 3 pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh